hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easy chairman bei
uns sind mark wann der usa und pakistans
in asien und die beiden sind teilnehmer
von unserer idee german summer school
der allerersten hier in berlin für eine
woche lernen wir jetzt deutsch zusammen
und heute gehen wir auf die straße und
fragen die leute was fragen wir was ist
in deine tasche los geht's
naja und hinter der kamera ist martina
martin hallo martin frey heute ist was
ist in deiner tasche nichts nichts ich
glücklich nicht dass nichts drin sollich
öffnen wir sehen ja leider nichts nicht
genau was ist in meiner tasche
witzigerweise ist nichts in meinem
rucksack weil ich habe diesen rucksack
gerade erst gekauft
secondhand und er ist sehr dreckig es
ist ein armee rückfragen heute was ist
in deiner tasche
das inkognito
was ist in meiner tasche ein portmonee
ein handy und ein paar taschentücher
ich habe mein portemonnaie
mein iphone ich habe ganz viel dass er
vielleicht jetzt
wenn du nur eine dinge oder eine sache
mitnimmt mitnehmen kannst was ist die
dinge würde sagen
wahrscheinlich ein gutes buch sogar
lesen willst du mal reinschauen
dann kannst du das ja selbst übersetzen
ok und was ist immer was ich sonst immer
mein handy ja ich bin da sehr abhängig
sehr gefährlich aber was ist in deine
tasche
mein handy ein portemonnaie ein deo und
was ist immer bei ihm dabei mein
portemonnaie mein schlüssel und das
iphone
was ist in deine tasche in meiner tasche
in meiner tasche ist er und ein messer
was zu trinken
geld schlüssel und führer und in der
tasche ist ein portemonnaie ein handy
eine visitenkarte eine wasserflasche
meine schlüssel ein stück käse ein stück
käse eine seifen schale
ich glaube das war's und was tust du da
gleich rein
das schloss ist das ist ein fall schloss
und das kann man schwierig irgendwie als
fahrer dran machen aus einer handtasche
4 und die habe ich nicht
deswegen mag sie in den rucksack dass
der rucksack nur für das schloss dabei
meine tasche ja heute morgen noch
gedacht es wird kälter
deswegen fully mitgenommen geldbeutel
handy das ist
ich habe alles möglich einen klamotten
immer der tasche weil ich gerade durch
deutschland trend von hamburg aus
wenigkeit gekommen doch gerade
angekommen deswegen habe ich mein ganzes
ganzen sack und pack hinten drin
ich war gerade in einer meiner alten
wohnung und musste noch sachen holen
deshalb sind diese komische sein
ich glaube das war's ich habe einen
schreibblock ich habe einen
kugelschreiber
ich habe eine schachtel zigaretten
nein die habe ich nicht lüge ein
feuerzeug kannst du uns anzeige
das kann ich nicht aufgrund des kriegs
waffengesetzes tut mir leid ich gestern
gekauft habe beim konzert - ganz kurz
gucken zwei trinkflaschen ein deo eine
hose meinte ja sowas gefährde handy
schließe ich glaube das ist das
wichtigste
das buch ja das wichtigste
meine stimme mein rap los
kruse ich habe auch gerade gekauft
ganz viele sagten etwas habe ich noch
ich habe meine schlüssel natürlich
ließen ganz unten sind immer sehr
schwierig zu finden
das kennen sie vielleicht auch was ist
denn da alles drin im rucksack frische
wäsche dann habe ich noch ein bisschen
technik von wegen kamera und
zusatz akku und was hab ich noch drin
süßigkeiten johann schmuck ich bring
deine party a wir verkaufen teile ihr
wollt 1 marti
sorry leute es muss jetzt zu trauern
leiter weiter ihr hört bald mehr von mir
das alles ja nicht dass das wahr was das
ja eine spezielle tasche
das ist eine kellner tasche eine kellner
tasche sagt ein kellner schürze mit
taschen integriert gerade ein was neues
in der tasche nämlich ein wasser
hallo leute wir sind jetzt zurück
an unserem ausgangspunkt hier haben wir
die andere gruppe wieder getroffen und
wir möchten uns jetzt verabschieden wir
hoffen euch hat unsere episode gefallen
und bevor witches sagen wollen wir noch
weiß dass lehrerin grüßen nämlich trauer
frieda und verankern
sie gucken immer in jakarta easy german
unterricht viele grüße an die spitze
studio spitze studium schule in jakarta
viele grüße wenn ihr auch mal lust hat
mit uns deutsch zu lernen was sind die
teilnehmer unserer ersten isidoro german
summer school dann guckt mal auf easy
line which causes dot com ist die
adresse
und kommt mir vorbei vielleicht kommt er
im winter zu unserer nächsten winter
school und wir können zusammen
deutschland in berlin
bei gewissen schon all ihren und
abonnieren
danke schön euch beiden danke tschüss